on est avant tout des passionnés de
football des passionnés de jeunes et je
pense que le travail qu'on fait le temps
qu'on leur accorde
c'est quelque chose de nécessaire et d'
absolument important donné de son temps
à notre jeunesse lui apporter les
fondamentaux c'est un sacrifice pour de
nombreux éducateurs quelle que soit la
discipline sportive
un dévouement qui leur donne un meilleur
goût à la vie surtout quand on a la
passion la passion on donne quand on
donne c'est dans l'espoir de recevoir et
avec eux je reçois j'ai un bon retour et
donc c'est pour ça que ça me donne
encore plus envie de les faire
progresser
ici nous sommes avec les u13 les 11 13
ans pour la première journée élite du
championnat en violet le racing club de
rivière pilote en jaune et bleu le
golden star section foot
cette année la ligue de football de
martinique a bien de vrais 18 clubs
trois groupes de six premières senti
pour les deux clubs du mythique le stade
serge rouge un lot pour le passé il
était difficile de trouver un siège
départ en 13e homme y trouver place et
ont pu assister à une rencontre de haute
tenue première grosse erreur de
rivière-pilote un cadeau pour lui livrer
prose qui ouvre le score
touché mais pas affaibli les pilotait
réagissent la pression est telle que
l'école des listes commettent la faute
bennett
michael rose réussi un but partout c'est
le score à la pause
en deuxième période les gold et nist
inscrivent un 2e but oeuvre du capitaine
louise les visiteurs réagissent égalise
sur coup franc sauf qu'une position
illicite annuler le but d piloter du sud
c'est clean de buzet si jusqu'à y avait
10 il y avait des difficultés et puis
voilà on n'était pas vraiment mon avis
on avait quelques petites fautes tâche a
été rude quand même et c'est la victoire
qui compte si on est tous très contents
de ce résultat
prochaine rencontre le 12 octobre le
golden star se déplace à case-pilote
face au club de la ville
le racing quant à lui reçoit l'uji
minéraux à rivière-pilote